Because we can communicate doesn't mean we're communicating the right things.
Animals live in harmony with nature in a very different way.
You know what I mean?
They kill for hunger,
you know what I mean?
They AIDS can kill for reasons that are non hunger related and things that
nature.
So we know that's a part of us,
but I,
I honestly think,
yeah,
I think we evolved from something that didn't necessarily look like us know.
Yeah.
It's,
that may have swung from a tree where the most advanced of the primates,
but we exhibit characteristics so we can see in the lower primates and if you
pay attention to all the top scientists who have spent studying human evolution,
they're all pretty much in agreement that there was something that we were all
similar too.
And they all branched off in a bunch of different ways.
It's amazing.
They keep finding new forms of people too.
Yeah,
I saw it.
I just found destined Noveon or something like that.
That's what it's called.
The one from Russia.
So do you think,
do you think Eileen has really popped down?
Fucked a monkey and we popped out nine months later and we go,
oh look,
that would be the most fun.
Yeah,
I think so.
Most fun thing if a pit stop happened and what was the movie that was really
crappy and not as good as it should have been?
That was the aliens like precursor or something.
It showed essentially where they can atheists,
atheists,
right.
They should have been very good at theory.
But yeah,
I think,
I think that that that's the possibility.
Aliens were chick hanging out at the moon,
said,
Yo,
look the blue plans to fucking go see what is and say Yo,
wow,
monkey looks great.
Fuck the shit out of it.
Got Out of there.
And the next thing you know you have war and pestilence and violence and poverty
and MMA.
Mm and joints.
But one monkey that accelerates past way past all the other ones.
Like one invention,
the invent,
the ability to communicate and the ability to having opposable thumbs to the
ability to communicate.
And then it started advancing.
As soon as he started talking,
started figuring out ways to express itself to each other.
And then they started making things and they're off to the races.
The next thing you know,
a couple of hundred thousand years later,
the world's different Pune.
It's like this thing erupts and then just covers a world with its shit.
Yeah.
And that's us.
How do you subscribe to the theory that we just may be a virus and the earth may
be getting rid of us?
Well,
no one would like to think that.
Right.
But the reason you call a vibe or something,
it's just an a,
a word that's been assigned to a living organism and a system by biomedical
science.
I mean,
we all know what a virus is.
It's a real thing.
It's amazing.
These brilliant people have discovered it and come up with vaccines to stop and
prevent them.
But it's a,
some sort of a life form really.
Essentially.
Now,
if we looked at the earth as being a living organism,
and so we should shirt,
it's certainly,
you could make an argument that it's a kind of a life form,
that it's a host of massive amounts of life yeah.
Of all the life.
Yeah.
Um,
you would think that maybe some of those things would not be in harmony.
Just like some of those things in the human body aren't in harmony,
right?
Your gut bacteria is off or you got a cold because there's bacteria in your body
that you picked up from a fucking bathroom somewhere or whatever.
Your sad,
all that stuff could easily apply to how human beings interact with the earth.
Are we the virus though?
Like when you got to look at it at some point the earth is,
Oh,
you are.
The theory is it's a living,
breathing organism.
Here's one I can say for sure.
Okay.
We are the virus to the ocean because we don't even look at them and think about
it.
That's life.
Before we were monkeys,
we were something that crawled out of the ocean.
Right?
Right.
Imagine if the earth,
the ocean was,
I mean,
I don't know what it was like.
We are kidding.
100 really stolen now.
This is where our phase one is to go,
were stoned as fuck.
I don't know what the ocean was like a couple hundred thousand years ago before
people really became what we are.
Tool tool using people that figured out how to get out into the ocean and
capture fish boon.
Imagine if you could see it.
Imagine if you could see an image of how many fucking fish were out there
200,000 years ago versus how many are now.
It's like they live next to a vampire that just keeps sucking the life out of
it.
I bet we've killed 50% of all life in the ocean.
That's what I'm saying.
We have to think of ourselves as some point.
You gotta say maybe the best thing human beings could do for the earth is,
is to end humanity.
Maybe,
but maybe viruses are there for a reason to maybe that it all needs to exist.
There needs to be some sort of a balance.
We're always trying to eliminate bad things.
Maybe they do serve some sort of weird fucking purpose.
So even even in that,
we find purpose is healing.
That's the talent of humans.
The ability to adjust and make logic out of us.
Being here.
Yeah.
Well,
and to keep moving and make more of us.